mais d'abord le fait majeur de cette
journée les tractations pour un accord
en vue des législatives à gauche les
détails avec Pierre-Henri olderborn
derrière cette grille les discussions
pour la nouvelle union populaire
écologiste et sociale s'enchaînent mais
pour parvenir un accord la France
insoumise l'âge du l'est afin de
convaincre le Parti socialiste nous si
nous étions amenés à désobéir ce serait
exclusivement pour pouvoir appliquer un
programme qui va dans un sens de plus
haut niveau écologique et social voilà
les choses sont claires il y a pas de
sortie de l'Europe ou que sais-je tout
ça est absurde et discussions permettent
de faire ces réglages des propos
adressés indirectement à la déclaration
du Premier secrétaire du BS je souhaite
que le terme désobéissance ne soit pas
inscrit dans notre plateforme en commune
je souhaite que nous puissions rappeler
que nous sommes donc inscrits dans un
cadre quel cadre européen qui n'ira pas
sorti de nid de l'Europe ni de l'euro
nous ne sommes pas des frexit une
demande également faite par les
écologistes
après une longue soirée de négociation
les verses unissent à la France
insoumises c'est exceptionnel en tout
cas que nous ayons réussi à nous mettre
d'accord penser législatives les accords
de cette alliance retraite à 60 ans
hausse du SMIC et la sortie du nucléaire
pourtant ce dernier point reste
toutefois un obstacle puisque les
communistes y sont favorables je pense
qu'il y a une préoccupation commune en
toute la gauche de toute façon faut
aller vers une transition
énergétique parce qu'il faut changer le
mix énergétique de la France nous
considérons que nous avons besoin du
nucléaire d'autres à gauche ne pensent
pas la même chose on a fait le Front de
Gauche ensemble on a fait d'autres
choses ensemble donc cette discussion
elle a toujours existé c'est pas une
question nouvelle et je pense qu'elle
est surmontable au train inquiétude des
deux parties la place de leurs candidat
dans les circonscriptions
et bien voilà c'est la fin du sujet je
l'avais alors je vais vous donner tout
de suite la cuisine de l'émission
manifestement de mon oreillette ne
fonctionne pas je le signale à mes amis
en régie j'accueil mes invités Joséphine
Staron bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
docteur en philosophie directrice des
études et des relations internationales
au sein du cercle de réflexion sinopia
et votre livre Europe la solidarité
contre le naufrage est justement publié
par les éditions sinopia Pascal Perino
bonsoir bienvenue pascalologue
professeur émérite à Sciences Po
Stéphane zumsteg bonsoir bienvenue
directeur du département Opinion chez
Ipsos et Mathieu croissanto
éditorialiste politique bonsoir Mathieu
bienvenue à vous la gauche alors à
l'heure où on vous parle en cette fin
d'après-midi on n'a pas encore l'accord
officiel du Parti socialiste le Parti
communiste a reçu un peu plus tard dans
la soirée mais on peut imaginer quand
même la gauche en route vers un accord
d'union pour ces législatives Joséphine
Staro est-ce que c'est une surprise pour
vous est-ce que finalement c'est pas la
conséquence logique des résultats du
premier tour de la de la présidentielle
c'est la conséquence logique c'est à
dire qu'on voyait trois blocs se
dessiner un bloc centriste autour
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis deux blocs
plus extrémistes à gauche et à droite et
donc l'Union des gauches qui semble se
dessiner aujourd'hui elle s'inscrit dans
cette dynamique dans cette recomposition
du paysage politique et si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est aussi tressé si je puis
dire pour constituer cette longue et
gauche c'est aussi parce qu'il y a un
symbole derrière la date choisi il
voudrait pouvoir annoncer dès cette nuit
ou demain matin donc le 3 mai la
création de cette union des gauches et
c'est pas sans rappeler la création du
Front populaire en 1936 le 3 mai donc
jour anniversaire donc ce serait
effectivement fort de symboles
maintenant attention s'il y a bien union
d'ego partie socialiste écologie et
communiste avec elle et fille une fois
mettons qu'il gagne beaucoup de sièges
au Parlement la deuxième bataille se
jouera ensuite à chaque vote de loi puis
on voit qu'il y a quand même des choses
qui sont irréconciliables entre toutes
ces formations politiques même s'ils
nous disent le contraire on va
évidemment y revenir et notamment et
notamment sur sur l'Europe parce qu'elle
Perrineau dans des négociations comme
celle de ces derniers jours qu'est-ce
qui compte le plus qu'est-ce qui se
négocie vraiment est-ce que c'est les
programmes au mot près vous voyez bien
que la sémantique avait son importance
pour Olivier Faure ou est-ce que
finalement c'est les circonscriptions
les plus gagnables le nombre de
circonscriptions je crois sans trahir de
secret que le nombre des
circonscriptions pour chacun
les questions financement derrière sont
importantes peut-être même essentielles
et qu'ensuite il faut habiller ça dans
une déclaration dans lequel on ne peut
pas dire tout de même n'importe quoi sur
surtout que ces gauches puisque on
redécouvre le terme de gauche puisque
faut savoir que la France insoumise
c'était passé pendant des années de la
référence à la gauche il s'agissait de
l'oligarchie contre le peuple là tout
d'un coup voilà Jean-Luc Mélenchon et la
France insoumise redécouvre son
appartenance à la gauche bien sûr parce
qu'il constitue le pôle principal et
qu'ils espèrent bien être le pôle autour
duquel se reconstruira la gauche de
demain mes enfants il faut savoir que
ces gauches ne partagent pas grand-chose
et que on parle de manière un peu
tronquée de l'union de la gauche ou de
la gauche pluriel parce que l'union de
la gauche même le Front populaire de
1936 c'était l'union entre les radicaux
les socialistes et le Parti communiste
ça n'allait pas jusqu'à la gauche de la
gauche ça n'allait pas jusqu'à l'extrême
gauche il faut savoir que dans les
négociations là aujourd'hui il y a
également le Nouveau Parti
Anticapitaliste c'est à dire que là
c'est une nouveauté radicale
c'est-à-dire que le Parti socialiste et
les Verts négocient avec la gauche de la
gauche avec la gauche radicale avec la
gauche vraiment extrême et ça c'est une
nouveauté dans l'histoire même du Parti
socialiste vous savez quand le Parti
communiste était né en 1920 à partir de
la SFIO Léon Blum disait moi il n'est
pas question je suis les communistes
qu'à l'époque était sur des positions
extrêmement révolutionnaires je garde la
vieille maison là au fond on se demande
quels sont les socialistes qui gardent
la vieille maison et ce qu'il n'y a pas
là un bouleversement mais mais total de
la stratégie de la gauche et de la
gauche de l'union de la gauche aussi
traditionnelle qui était celle de
Mitterrand celle de Jospin Stéphane
zoumsteak en disent les électeurs ils
demandaient l'Union depuis depuis
longtemps est-ce que est-ce que ça on
peut imaginer une remobilisation encore
une fois si un accord intervient dans la
perspective de ces législatives
évidemment la grande incertitude si la
gauche articulée autour de la France
insoumise souhaite de devenir la
principale force de position auprès des
Bourbon ce sera possible que si elle
arrive à garder ses électeurs du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle et
franchement les choses ne vont pas de
soi
il 25 ans l'abstention était
relativement limitée à la présidentielle
22% des Français n'avaient pas voté au
premier tour quelques semaines après 51%
des Français n'allaient pas voter aux
élections législatives il est là le
risque pour pour cette coalition de
gauche qui est en train de naître ce
risque de pèse pas sur la majorité
présidentielle sur Emmanuel Macron pas
du tout mais sur cette gauche là si la
gauche n'arrive pas à garder une grande
partie de ces électorats du premier tour
de la présidentielle elle est condamnée
à non pas à disparaître évidemment mais
avoir des marges de progression très
limitée pourquoi parce que sans rentrer
dans le détail de la loi électorale que
tout le monde connaît avec 50%
d'abstention à l'échelle nationale vous
devez dans une circonscription obtenir
25% des voix ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
pas de triangulaire je crois de mémoire
il y a eu qu'une seule triangulaire il y
a 5 ans alors que lors de scrutin
précédent ça pouvait être quelques
dizaines pour que des parties radicaux
ça va aussi pour les Sandra d'ailleurs
est une chance d'emporter un nombre
important de de siège il faut une
triangulaire si vous n'êtes qu'en duel
vous pouvez gagner et probablement que
la gauche notamment la France insoumise
progressera en nombre de sièges mais en
termes de duel il y a un moment donné où
les électeurs
vous avez face à vous un candidat
central et un candidat d'extrême
d'extrême droite ou d'extrême gauche
il y a un élément dont on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé même si évidemment la
France insoumise est allée très vite
finalement en une semaine presque tout
est bouclé c'est que quand il y aura des
duels France insoumise contre un
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
là pour le coup il y aura un vrai effet
repoussoir de la part de ce qu'il reste
de l'électorat de droite de la droite
d'opposition et de l'extrême droite
parce que en général ces électorats sont
très hostiles à l'égard de la gauche
est-ce qu'il y avait quand même une
demande d'union de la part des électeurs
de gauche dans les dans les sondages
d'opinion qui était fait dans les
semaines ou même les mois qui sont
passionné la Président on l'avait vu
notamment lors de l'épisode de la
candidature la non-candidature de
Christiane Taubira de de cette sorte de
de primaire bien sûr c'était un souhait
maintenant la nouveauté c'est que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a obtenu un excellent
score 22%, il a écrasé les autres
candidats de gauche est-ce que cette
électorat de gauche est notamment de
centre gauche qui c'est vrai en partie à
voter utile et à voter pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon suivra cette démarche lors des
élections législatives pour l'instant
rien n'est moins sûr Joséphine Staron ça
change quand même la donne pour pour ces
élections législatives notamment pour la
majorité présidentielle est-ce que c'est
une nouvelle menace qui a qui apparaît
oui c'est une menace et d'ailleurs on
voit bien que aux parties uniques de
gauche Emmanuel Macron essaye de
d'opposer un parti unique de du centre
et essayer de rassembler autour de lui
les centristes de gauche les centristes
de droite et puis les quelques
dissidents ou ceux qui pourraient être
on va dire Macron compatible donc ce qui
a l'air de se dessiner aujourd'hui c'est
à nouveau c'est comme on l'a vu pendant
les présidentielles mais là de manière
beaucoup plus organisée cette fois-ci
c'est cette tripartition avec un centre
fort et deux extrêmes on voit quand même
que même si effectivement la loi
électorale va rendre plus compliqué
l'élection d'une majorité de députés
bien évidemment rassemblement national
ou France insoumise ils font néanmoins
des scores plus importants qu'ils en ont
fait par le passé ce qui
mathématiquement diminue la majorité du
président
on voit les scores que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a pu faire dans certaines
villes au premier tour ou que Marine Le
Pen a pu faire dans certaines villes au
second ça leur garantit pas enfin voilà
il faut faire un peu de vous vous
connaissez ça par cœur mais mais il faut
redire que ça ne garantit pas des
victoires similaires au législatives
bien sûr c'était fini le vote législatif
ça n'est pas un vote présidentiel la
question électorale a changé la
circonscription change il va y avoir 577
ça conscriptions il faut pas croire que
les forces extrémistes que ce soit le
rassemblement national ou la France
insoumise ont beaucoup donné de femmes
qui sont connus sur le terrain qui sont
connus dans ces 577 circonscriptions
donc attention c'est pour ça que tous
les sondages d'intention de vote
légitime qui ont pu être fait sur des
étiquettes partisanes ne mesurent rien
ne mesure rien parce que c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe et d'autre part vous
aurez Stéphane vient de le dire vous
aurez un mouvement inévitable
d'abstention différentielle c'est-à-dire
on sait très bien que dans les élections
législatives qui viennent dans l'ombre
d'une élection présidentielle il y a un
mouvement d'abstention massive mais même
avec une union de la gauche qui n'est
pas arrivé depuis des années mais bien
sûr surtout que c'est union de la gauche
et les particuliers chez beaucoup de
gens ils vont se poser la question ils
avaient toute une partie des lecteurs
socialistes qui a voté pour Emmanuel
Macron vous croyez que une union de la
gauche sous influence mélenchonistes
majeur va attirer ces électeurs bien sûr
que non et donc les oppositions vont se
dire largement la messe est dit voilà
c'est pas la peine d'y aller on
n'arrivera pas à redresser à la
Législative le vote présidentiel et
d'autre part ceux qui ont gagné ils sont
moins touchés par cette vague
absentionniste donc dans cette
abstention différentielle en général la
majorité présidentielle retrouve peu
auproux une majorité législative bon
alors celui qui est au centre du jeu on
l'a bien compris c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon une réaction c'était hier en
marge des manifestations du 1er mai de
la fête du travail
c'est passé quand même un événement qui
est d'une grande ampleur politique la
décision de Monsieur fort c'est une
décision
pardon de parler comme ça mais je ne
m'attendais pas à sa nuit quoi tout d'un
coup bon il dit maintenant c'est bon
quoi on est arrivé à virgule 7 la suite
c'est quoi donc on arrête on arrête avec
cette ligne là on essaye on part dans
une autre direction que moi je considère
comme plus conforme à l'histoire longue
du Parti socialiste
du Parti socialiste mais pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a quitté le PS en 2008 il
y a cette dimension quand même de
revanche personnelle oui c'est une
revanche la peau de Solférino comme il
disait il voulait la peau des
socialistes des solfériens
c'est très discutable ce qu'il dit sur
l'histoire longue je rejoins la réaction
de Pascal Perino parce que c'est vrai
qu'on assiste à un séisme une certaine
façon à gauche puisque au-delà du fait
que ce soit aps et et France insoumise
c'est deux les deux visages de la gauche
qui existent en France depuis 150 ans
le traditionnel opposition entre guêpes
et Jaurès mais on en est là c'est à dire
que Jaurès c'était allé vers mais
comprendre le réel et ce que on reproche
une partie de la gauche socialiste
réformiste reprochait à la gauche de la
gauche c'était justement de ne pas
comprendre de faire figurer elle parce
qu'il y en a certains qui sont
réformistes et progressistes qui veulent
changer c'est la théorie des petits pas
et au-delà du sol Parti socialiste c'est
toute une partie d'électorat c'est toute
une partie du mouvement syndical c'est
la CFDT et puis de l'autre côté c'est
des gens qui veulent renverser la table
parce qu'il considèrent qu'ils veulent
changer de paradigme parce que leur
système le système de leur convient pas
et ça c'est le terrain que la bourre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec un certain
succès il faut le reconnaître et puis
des gens qui se disent ben oui on est
arrivé au bout du bout faut peut-être
changer le paradigme plutôt que
d'essayer de rafistoler de corriger le
système ou de ou de mettre des sparades
donc c'est c'est une un vrai schisme
enfin c'est un vrai schisme qui est en
train de se créer avec un grand
vainqueur qui est la gauche radicale et
celle de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui en tout cas dans cet accord
électoral mais Stéphane on peut on peut
se dire aussi que au sein du PS mais
aussi d'Europe Écologie Les Verts ça
oblige à une clarification
de choisir une ligne quoi parler des
appareils parler de l'électorat parce
que les appareils pour l'instant
évidemment mais on voit bien notamment
en ce qui concerne les parties
socialistes on voit bien les appels au
secours de François Hollande et dont on
connaît l'attachement à l'histoire du
Parti socialiste pour le coup il y a une
vraie sincérité quand il s'exprime on a
bien vu ce que les maires des grandes
villes qui avaient formé l'ossature en
tout cas au début de la campagne de Dani
dalgo de réagissent non ils ne sont pas
d'accord parce que ils ont bien compris
que derrière c'est un effacement donc il
y a deux stratégies il y a les sortants
qui veulent coûte que coûte sauver leur
siège et on imagine mal comment il
pourrait sauver leur siège sans union
avec les autres parties de gauche et il
y a les cassis qui eux jouent autre
chose parce qu'ils ont d'autres mandats
des grandes villes par exemple ou des
régions évidemment qui ne sont pas
menacées dans quelques semaines mais on
va droit vers l'inclosion enfin une
implosion du PS ou ce qu'il en reste est
totalement tout à fait envisageable dans
les jours qui viennent si l'accord est
signé si l'accord est jugé trop léonin
par la partie on va dire la plus
autonomie soit indépendante du PS moi je
n'exclut pas que tout explose en fait
oui des personnages importants Patrick
Kanner qui est le président a déjà dit
qu'il n'en voulait pas de de cet accord
donc il y a d'autres voies comme ça
forte qui se sont exprimés vous avez
cité celle de François Hollande et
virale évidemment alors celui qui est
alors à la manœuvre en cette fin
d'après-midi pour le Parti socialiste
puisque jusqu'à présent les les
discussions de ce faisait pas en sa
présence c'est Olivier fort le premier
secrétaire on l'écoute ce justifier sur
la ligne de ce nouvel attelage
concernant notamment l'Europe les
traités européens moi je suis un
Européen convaincu et je n'ai aucune
envie de mettre fin à cette immense
aventure que nous avons construite
depuis la prière par la prière mondiale
et que nous avons besoin de consolider
mais ça veut dire que tout fonctionne
parfaitement la réponse est NON et
est-ce qu'on ne voit pas une défiance
naître jour après jour parmi les
Européens eux-mêmes la réponse est oui
jusqu'au point que on a des Anglais qui
ont em franchi la barre avec le brexit
la rédaction du texte et donc ça suppose
qu'on fasse en sorte que l'Europe parle
aux Européens
Olivier Faure est-ce qu'il est légitime
Joséphine s'arrond alors que sa
stratégie finalement que ce soit sa
candidate tout sa stratégie pour la
présidentielle ça aboutit à moins de 2%
des voix
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un discours
qui est représente quand même toute une
partie de la gauche la gauche modérée la
gauche centriste une gauche
historiquement attachée à l'Union
européenne et à une forme de de
coopération
européenne internationale qui n'est pas
dans l'ADN de la France insoumise et on
entend presque un cri de détresse de la
part d'Olivier Faure qui dit non
peut-être pas trop le choix de nous
rallier à LFI pour exister mais en
revanche nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
devons pas transiger sur l'attachement à
l'Union européenne et là ça va être très
compliqué parce que même si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon revient un peu se
déradicaliser on va dire sur sa position
vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne en
disant non nous ne sortirons pas l'Union
européenne qu'en est-il de l'OTAN
dans la campagne la sortie de l'OTAN
restait un élément clé qu'en est-il des
sanctions vis-à-vis de la Russie qui là
encore
cristallise une forme d'opposition entre
des élus écologistes et socialistes qui
soutiennent des sanctions encore plus
dures et elle est fille qui s'y oppose
donc on a quand même des points de
divergence qui sont forts et pour ce que
ce que ce que ce que dit aujourd'hui
Olivier Faure c'est de garder au sein de
cette union des gauches une ligne
politique traditionnelle du Parti
socialiste et d'une forme de centre
gauche qui est un attachement
inconditionnel à l'Union européenne même
si bien évidemment il y a des choses à
réformer à revoir mais réformer et
revoir dans un parti de gouvernement
comme l'aile Parti socialiste et bien ça
ne veut pas dire forcément taper du
point sur la table ou faire la politique
de la chaise vide comme pourrait
éventuellement le proposer elle est
fille si ils étaient au pouvoir demain
périno un coup d'oeil sur ce qui se
passe aussi chez Europe Écologie Les
Verts eux ils ont signé l'accord ils
disent tous accords historique est-ce
que on peut dire que c'est la ligne
Sandrine Rousseau qui l'emporte
oui un peu d'une certaine manière
pourquoi parce que vous savez c'est tout
le problème des appareils d'un côté et
des électeurs de l'autre et les
appareils sont de moins en moins
représentatifs des électorats vous savez
je regardais une enquête ce matin je
crois que 54% des électeurs d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts au premier tour de la
présidentielle
sont favorables à la présidence et à la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron
et on voit bien que l'appareil d'Europe
Écologie univers c'est pas du tout cela
parce que c'est un appareil quand vous
regardez son histoire qui est un
appareil où beaucoup d'hommes et de
femmes d'ailleurs viennent de la gauche
extrême et en cela ils ont toujours eu
un problème pour représenter leur
électorat donc ils peuvent très bien eux
s'engager dans cette voie ça ne veut pas
dire du tout que les cinq et quelques
pourcents d'électeurs écologistes du
premier tour se retrouveront derrière
une telle je crois que là il va y avoir
certainement des déceptions pour les
tenants de cette union populaire ils
sont déconnectés largement de leur
électorat comme si Monsieur fort choisit
l'alliance voilà il faudra faire passer
la pilule à tous ces électeurs
socialistes qui sont en effet pour une
attitude extrêmement sévère vis-à-vis de
la Russie qui n'ont aucune complaisance
pour les régimes autoritaires qui
parfois suscite l'intérêt de Monsieur
Mélenchon vous voyez c'est un peu on
parlait tout à l'heure en effet du vieux
débat dans le dans les gauches de la
réforme et de la Révolution et bien on y
est à nouveau moralité ce nom la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale nups la nupes fossil habitait
pour longtemps parce qu'elle Perrino ou
pas
ça peut très vite éclater et puis la
conjoncture électorale y est pour
beaucoup je demande à voir
qui n'en restera à la rentrée prochaine
suivre ça évidemment Matthieu il y a
cette nouvelle union de la gauche
évidemment elle se construit voilà on
l'a déjà débattu ici plusieurs fois mais
dans l'espoir d'une majorité élisez-moi
Premier ministre dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon
l'espoir d'une majorité au législative
est-ce que c'est crédible pour vous non
ce matin Julien Bayou le disait sur BFM
TV nous pouvons aller chercher une
majorité dans ce pays est-ce qu'il faut
le croire on sait que depuis la mise en
place du quinquennat l'inversion du
calendrier on l'a dit ici il y a un
effet de souffle assez mécanique qu'il y
a à la fois à l'abstention et à la
mobilisation des Français qui au fond
veulent un choix cohérent avec
l'élection du Président de la République
et ne veulent pas ajouter du chaos au
chaos parfois et puis ce serait tout à
fait inédit et surprenant là que ça
arrive pour la première fois on rappelle
que la France en plus n'a jamais été
autant à droite quand on interroge les
Français je parle souvent de contrôle
ils se disent quand même plutôt de
droite et que le total gauche de la
présidentielle atteint quand même
péniblement les 30% avec une partie des
électeurs qui sont portés sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le rappelait ne goûteront
peut-être guerre des espèces d'union de
dernière minute il faut se demander
pourquoi il le fait qu'elle manque de
quelle majorité il parle Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en fait c'était assez habile
d'une certaine façon ceux il lisez moi
Premier ministre même si c'était
complètement boeux d'un point de vue
institutionnel et on verra peut-être
dans dans un mois et quelques si c'était
boîte politiquement mais c'était c'était
en fait pour remobiliser enfin maintenir
la mobilisation de ces électeurs leur
offrir un débouché politique ou un
semblant de débouché politique et
surtout s'afficher en première opposant
à Emmanuel Macron et de ce point de vue
c'est plutôt réussi parce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le fait avec des
arrière-pensées électorales certes mais
ils croient fondamentalement qu'il peut
reconstruire la gauche c'est vrai que
c'était un terme qui n’employait plus on
se rappeler que son premier parti
s'appelait le fronto partie de gauche
puis le Front de Gauche c'était sa
vieille idée de reconstruire la gauche
au-delà de cette frontière et donc en
apprenant sur sa gauche si j'ose dire et
la majorité présidentielle est-ce
qu'elle reste en par conséquent beaucoup
mieux placé pour l'emporter oui de par
cet effet mécanique dont on parlait de
part les sondages même s'ils ne veulent
pas dire grand-chose il y en a eu un au
soir du premier tour qui disait que sur
le papier en tout cas elle bénéficierait
d'une grande majorité mais tout ça je
disais c'est sur le papier et la
question c'est moins de savoir de quel
c'est plutôt de savoir de quelle nature
et de quel ampleur sera cette majorité
est-ce qu'elle sera large et disciplinée
comme c'était le cas en 2017 est-ce
qu'elle sera un peu plus courte et
frondeuse comme c'était le cas avec
François Hollande en 2012 est-ce qu'il
s'agira d'une majorité absolue ou d'une
majorité relative comme avec connu
Michel Rocard en 88 qui avait été obligé
de composer avec les communistes et avec
les centristes pour gouverner et puis
surtout de quoi ou plutôt de qui sera
telle composée en 2017 toussait tout
était simple avec 317 députés elle seule
la République en marche était assuré de
pouvoir mener la politique qu'elle
voulait et voter les lois qu'elle
voulait en 2022 ça se complique car la
majorité pour être plus éclatée avec on
le voit l'émergence d'un nouveau parti
l'aile droite incarné par Edouard
Philippe et son parti horizon qui
menaçait quand même jusqu'à la semaine
dernière de présenter des candidats
contre les candidats de la République en
marche parce qu'il s'estimé maltraité
pas associé aux investitures les
réunions dimanche où il a été associé il
y a une réunion dimanche soir ou une
n'était pas associée donc on voit bien
que là c'est une source de tension parce
qu'une majorité le composite c'est pas
facile à gérer et quand on y ajoute des
velléités présidentielles comme celle de
l'ancien Premier ministre une exigence
d'être bien traitée d'être respecté
comme celle du MoDem de François Bayon
par exemple ou encore une volonté de
peser comme celle dite de l'aile ou de
gauche de la majorité et ben ça risque
de devenir beaucoup beaucoup plus
compliqué Stéphane la probabilité d'une
majorité relative est-ce qu'elle est
plus forte que qui a 5 ans dans votre
esprit plus fort un peu plus fort je
pense que c'est peu probable que le
Président de la République ne dispose
pas d'une majorité absolue qu'elle soit
composée uniquement la République en
marche ou des de ses alliés mais je
pense c'est peu propre c'est pas
impossible mais pour toutes les raisons
comme on a dit il faudrait que la gauche
la gauche a une cinquantaine de députés
aujourd'hui
c'est on imagine difficilement qu'elle
pourrait obtenir de 100 sièges de plus
ou même sans siège de plus et surtout
faut pas oublier une chose il y a pas un
bloc antimacon contre le bloc
présidentiel le positionne les
oppositions sont facturés il y a la
droit il y a l'extrême droite d'un côté
et il y a cette union de la gauche c'est
pas la même chose et c'est ne
s'additionne pas évidemment donc je
trouve je trouve cette hypothèse très
très peu probable d'autant plus que
évidemment que la gauche devrait
progresser grâce à cette union
modérément ou de façon spectaculaire
mais pas jusqu'au point d'atteindre la
majorité mais il y a la droite la
principale force de position au panier
bourgeon aujourd'hui ce sont les 100
sièges de LR on va y revenir dans un
instant mais il est tout à fait possible
que les gains de la gauche en termes de
siège se fasse non pas au détriment de
sortant de la République en marche mais
au détriment de la droite qui serait
éliminé dès le premier tour et on a déjà
dans cette émission consacrée beaucoup
de temps à la question de du
rassemblement national mais c'est pareil
pour le rassemblement national le le
raisonnement que vous faites les uns et
les autres concernant LFI ou cette
nouvelle union de la gauche vaut pour le
rassemblement national bien sûr mais
d'ailleurs ce qui est ce qui est notable
c'est quand vous entendez les principaux
responsables à commencer par le
président par intérim de du
rassemblement national parlé de ses
objectifs en ce qui concerne les
législatives il est très prudent il
parle de l'objectif c'est d'avoir un
groupe un groupe c'est 15 on n'est pas
on n'est plus à l'époque où le front
puis le rassemblement national expliqué
qu'il voulait sans 150 ou de son siège
il parle d'un groupe c'est 15 on aura
peut-être un peu plus parce que sinon on
leur dira c'est un échec vous vouliez 80
et vous en faites 64 c'était le scrutin
qu'il aurait été le plus défavorable
parce que cette modestie est
certainement liée tout de même le
parallélisme des formes ça existe
regarder on est là en train de commenter
l'alliance entre les modérés de gauche
avec la gauche extrémisme à droite
que dirait-on si LR rentrée en
négociation pendant 10 jours avec leur
rassemblement national vous voyez ça ça
surprendrait donc à droite il n'y a pas
cette atmosphère d'union des droites
Zemmour là plus de ces vœux n'est jamais
venu et donc le rassemblement national
lui qui en plus de ça prend de haut
reconquête le rassemblement national est
réduit vraiment à sa pure logique de
rassemblement national mais c'est quand
même un joli coup pardon je reviens sur
le sur cette nouvelle populaire là à
gauche c'est quand même un joli coup
alors peut-être pour l'instant
médiatique si je vous entends les uns et
les autres mais en tout cas ça ça
fonctionne c'est un joli coup et ça peut
créer une attente quand même il faut
connaître que le président de France
insoumise là pour en effet c'est gérer
son agenda médiatique on est bien
d'accord Joséphine Staron est-ce que ce
calendrier finalement cette union
populaire à gauche en train de se faire
encore une fois on est on est prudent à
l'heure on vous parle dans cette fin
d'après-midi est-ce que ça oblige quand
même Emmanuel Macron à faire des
concessions c'est à dire qu'à construire
lui aussi une majorité présidentielle un
peu plus solide Mathieu évoquait le
parti horizon Édouard Philippe
puisque en fait il y a plusieurs
hypothèses effectivement comme vous le
disiez est-ce qu'il va avoir une
majorité absolue avec des députés
disciplinés comme il a eu jusque là ça
c'est peu probable on risque d'avoir
quand même une majorité pour Emmanuel
Macron avec des députés si ce n'est
frondeurs du moins qui vont poser des
questions qui ne vont pas forcément
voter
toutes les lois que Emmanuel Macron
voudrait faire voter pendant ce deuxième
quinquennat et notamment sur les
questions sociales puisqu'il doit
essayer de rassembler sur sa gauche il
va devoir faire quelques concessions au
niveau social on le voit avec
françoise-saône qui essaye lui aussi de
rallier la partie de centre gauche
autour d'Emmanuel Macron et puis plutôt
à droite on a la partie Edouard Philippe
avec horizon qui qui joue déjà sa partie
depuis quelques mois il n'a pas attendu
la fin du deuxième tour donc il a une
certaine avance mais on entend dire que
Emmanuel Macron prendrait ça peut-être
non pas à la légère mais en tout cas
avec une forme d'agacement ou presque
d'ironie donc il faut quand même se
méfier puisque Édouard Philippe presque
une des personnalités préférées des
Français et ça ça compte ça compte
surtout lorsqu'on est face à un choix
qui est un non choix puisque beaucoup
d'électeurs vont à nouveau se retrouver
dans une situation où ils vont choisir
par défaut ou alors s'abstenir donc là
la question de la personnalité peut
jouer un petit élément dans l'équation
c'est que Emmanuel Macron est pas un
président qui s'en va mais bientôt ou
presque c'est à qui il est à peine
investi que les gens vont certains vont
se poser la question de la suite ils
sont pose cela pose déjà donc à tendront
2 ans doit attendre 3 ans non mais ça
fait 8 jours qu'il est rééluia mais vous
avez raison
quand vous avez un parti aussi mou et
gazeux que la République en marche s'il
y avait le président qui était là parce
qu'on se disait voilà faut pas que je me
fâche avec le président est-ce que
j'aurai mon investiture au final c'est
lui qui fait la pluie le beau temps et
plus le temps ça sera plus celle-là
c'est une façon plus le cas et dès
maintenant oui et puis on voit là tout
de même l'échec de la République en
marche la République en marche aurait dû
être un appareil qui fasse vivre la
diversité de droite et de gauche en sont
simples il a échoué et donc ce à quoi en
assiste c'est un macronisme de droite
consistant qui qui existe avec agir avec
horizon et puis ça commence à gauche
Jean-Pierre Chevènement a créé sa petite
organisation voilà parce que l'horizon
va être en dehors de Macron en tant que
tel donc il faut des horizons de droite
et des horizons de gauche dans la Macron
Stéphane zumsteak pour l'instant c'est
le pied gauche d'Emmanuel Macron si on
analyse son électorat il est il est
aussi puissant que son pied droit non
mais c'est comme on a beaucoup parlé de
la droitisation du programme d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est la première fois que
quelqu'un est lu son triste ou de Centro
parce que il était étiquet on va dire
centre c'est pas la première fois que
des candidats de gauche ou de centre de
gauche droitisent leur politique une
fois qu'ils sont au pouvoir mais la
vraie singularité cette fois-ci c'est
qu'il y a une substitution d'une partie
d'électorat c'est pas juste qu'il a
droitisé des propositions en 2017 il y a
plus de gens qui viennent de la gauche
que des gens qui viennent de la droite
qui votent pour lui au premier tour des
choses ont évidemment évolué rapidement
et massivement
tout au long de ces cinq ans notamment
vu lors des élections européennes de
2019 mais il y a toujours des gens des
socio-démocrates des écologistes des
gens pour qui la vie se déroule dans des
très bonnes conditions qui vivent dans
des centres villes sans parler de bobos
c'est pas ça mais il y a toujours ses
anciens représentants du centre rouge
qui sont macronistes qui ne se disent
pas de droite ils sont ils votent pour
ils votent pour lui il continue de voter
pour lui et c'est ce qu'on disait aussi
il y a des gens qui ont voté écologistes
aux européennes qui comptaient voter
pour Yannick Jadot qui au dernier moment
ont voté pour Mélenchon parce que la
gauche avait peut-être une chance de ne
pas être ridicule le but était pas de se
qualifier mais au moins de ne pas être
ridicule et la gauche n'a pas été
ridicule pas du tout grâce à Mélenchon
ces gens là je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
suivront l'aventure de l'union de la
gauche ils vont revenir quelque part une
sorte de vote de vote modérée
raisonnable deux centres gauche ils sont
de moins en moins nombreux ces gens là
mais ils existent toujours ils peuvent
peser ils pourraient abandonner une fois
de plus la gauche au profit de ce bloc
central le l'offensive je sais pas si
c'est le bon terme enfin tout comme la
tentative rêve ça mène pour l'instant ça
fait pschit on en entend quand même très
peu parlé d'ailleurs très peu parlé et
pourtant c'est quelque chose d'urgent le
macronisme s'il veut continuer à exister
a besoin d'équilibre et là dans la
dernière période il y a un déséquilibre
je regarde je crois que ce sont les
données Ipsos quand vous regardez sur
santé lecteur vraiment macronien le
noyau dur du premier tour vous en aviez
deux tiers qui se positionnent à droite
voyez on voit bien le la rupture de
l'équilibre peut-être que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon va faciliter la tâche de Noël
certains nombre de grands élus ou de
grandes figures du PS plutôt réformiste
et sociaux-démocrate ont peut-être du
coup céder aux sirènes du pouvoir
pour terminer ce premier débat un gros
plan sur sur le parti LR avec Marion
Vigreux bonsoir Marion bienvenue sur ce
plateau donc on revient sur cette
succession de
désistement pour les législatives qui
touchent les républicains
aujourd'hui entre 15 et 20 et lui a
renoncé à se présenter au législatif et
la raison à cela c'est tout d'abord la
peur d'une déroute le score de
l'élection présidentielle 4,8% en
décourage plus d'un ainsi l'adjoint en
mer danger Maxence Henry qui s'était
pourtant présenté en 2012 et en 2017
renonce cette fois-ci alors que la
Fédération lui gardait une place sur
Angers Sud voici ce qu'il déclarait la
semaine dernière le contexte politique
fait que je n'ai aucune chance de passer
qui voudrait aller s'abîmer dans une
élection avec une candidate qui a fait
moins de 5% s'abîmer politiquement mais
aussi financièrement on rappelle que
pour les législatives comme pour les
présidentielles les frais de campagne ne
sont remboursés qu'à partir à de 5% le
propose bien un prêt de 5000 euros pour
les candidats mais pour une campagne
législative vaut encore mobiliser des
fonds personnels et certains ne veulent
pas s'y risquer avec la démission de
Maxence Henry dans le Maine-et-Loire les
discussions ont donc repris avec l'UDI
et les centristes pour trouver un
nouveau candidat nous avons contacté le
sénateur du Maine-et-Loire Stéphane
piénoir qui est le président de la
Fédération locale et vous allez le voir
il n'est pas très inquiet une
candidature à une législative c'est
évidemment des fentes des valeurs mais
c'est aussi une aventure personnelle
avec une exposition pas seulement
financière c'est une exposition sur son
nom propre je comprends que certains
puissent se sentir fragilisés dans cette
aventure mais néanmoins nous souhaitons
avoir des candidats partout c'est
possible et une quinzaine ou une
vingtaine de désistement à l'échelle des
577 circonscriptions ça reste quand même
relativement marginal il faut quand même
le souligner
Marion il y a un autre argument qui est
mis en avant par ces candidats
démissionnaires c'est le besoin de
refonte du parti dans le Morbihan
vice-président du conseil départemental
a renoncé à se présenter sur la
circonscription de Pontivy j'ai défendu
une ligne politique pour la campagne
présidentielle avec conviction après
l'échec de Valérie Pécresse il ne me
semble pas possible de défendre son
projet dans ce contexte si elle croit
toujours au potentiel politique de la
droite républicaine elle veut
effectivement désormais s'engager dans
la recomposition de son parti mais en
s'appuyant sur son mandat local en étant
au plus près des électeurs un choix qui
selon la sénatrice des Bouches-du-Rhône
Valérie Boyer et la conséquence du non
cumule des mandats et de la façon dont
le Parlement a été traité pendant cinq
ans par Emmanuel Macron voici ce qu'elle
nous dit je comprends que certains élus
préfèrent conserver leur mandats locaux
pour agir dans leur mairie dans leur
région plutôt qu'être un parlementaire
isolé et sans pouvoir à conclusion à ce
stade les républicains pour les
républicains un mouvement ne sont pas
jugés alarmants ce sont même finalement
des ajustements logiques après une
séquence présidentielle et chez LR on
est persuadé que le score sera bien
meilleur au présidentiel les
républicains présenteront leur liste
officielle pour les législatives ce
samedi à l'occasion à d'un congrès
national avec l'UDI et les centres merci
Marion pour toutes ces informations
Pascal pyrino Le LR c'est aujourd'hui le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale bon on imagine
qu'ils ne peuvent que reculer vous les
imaginez à quel étiage dans dans cette
semaine
ils peuvent perdre mais en écoutant le
ce qui vient d'être dit tout de même
attention on s'aperçoit aussi que les
députés les députés sortants peuvent
être l'objet d'une relative intoxication
ils ont projeté le score de Valérie
pécressecription là en effet il y a de
quoi presque abandonner les 101 c'est la
prescription que elle est approche et ça
se passera voilà ça se passera
différemment je ne veux pas les rassurer
seulement mais ça se passera
différemment d'autant plus que LR reste
un grand parti tout de même très très
inséré dans les collectivités
départementales dans les collectes dans
beaucoup de communes deux tiers des
communes de plus de 20 000 habitants
sont contrôlés par LR et ses alliés donc
voilà beaucoup de régions aussi donc il
feront de la résistance ou de la
résilience on verra bien fin juin de
quoi il s'agit mais je crois qu'en plus
de ça le refus d'alliance avec leur
rassemblement national fait que pour les
électeurs de droite de gouvernement
modérés il y a là un pôle qui continue à
exister et qui rassemble l'UDI le
nouveau centre LR et que sur cette base
là ils pourront faire réexister leurs
différences avant bien sûr de
reconstruire le grand parti de droite
qui était l'air mais ça ça sera pour les
années qui viennent et le président
encore président actuel c'est Christian
Jacob évidemment qui a annoncé lui-même
qui ne se représenterait pas à la
députation on l'écoute tirer un peu le
bilan et pointu du doigt d'autres que
lui
ceux qui ont rejoint Emmanuel Macron en
2017 ont contribué largement à la
situation catastrophique dans laquelle
on est il y a quand vous avez 40% de
vote de désespérance en France ça n'est
ça n'est pas rien les gens qui se sont
reportés et qui ont voté pour Marine Le
Pen ou pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon sont pas
d'un côté des fascistes de l'autre côté
des déjeuners et cervelets maoïste ça
n'est pas ça
va de désespérance comme bien évidemment
c'est sa responsabilité directe c'est
d'abord la gestion dès le début de son
de son mandat avec avec Edouard Philippe
ou ce tandem nous a amené dans cette
situation
Joséphine steron et s'il y a pas quand
même une part de déni de sa propre
responsabilité de la part de Christian
Jacob si mais pas que de sa propre
responsabilité et de la responsabilité
du parti républicain tout comme de celle
du Parti socialiste on avait deux
parties de gouvernement fort qui
qui sont tombés dans le piège que leur
attendu Emmanuel Macron en 2017 et qui
ne s'en sont pas relevés et qui n'ont
pas utilisé ces cinq années de mandats
pour se reconstruire et ce on va dire se
renforcer se solidifier les divisions
les divisions les ont on va dire des
divisées presque définitivement donc il
y aura une reconstruction mais en
revanche je pense comme Monsieur Perino
qu'il faut être plus optimiste sur les
élections législatives puisque les
Français vont bien distinguer le
National du local et avec leur ancrage
local très fort les républicains ont une
assise solide tout comme dans une
certaine mesure le PS même si c'est un
peu moins de quand même
bien moindre et donc les français
risquent de voter davantage pour ceux
qui connaissent même si l'étiquette LR
ne leur parle plus et c'est là-dessus
que joue tous les tous les LR qui qui
restent et qui se représentent
aujourd'hui
on peut peut-être terminer là-dessus
cette notion d'encrage local c'est quand
même moins puissant pour une législative
que pour une municipale on est bien
d'accord parce que les électeurs voient
des réalisations concrètes de la part de
leur municipalité ne le voit pas de
façon concrète à l'échelle de leur
circonscription pour un député moi je
suis comme un peu inquiet pour pour ce
qui va rester des LR à l'issue de ces
élections législatives de quelle alerte
par le ton ce qui est vont rester
autonome indépendants de ceux qui vont
être tentés par un aliment par une
satellisation par la macronie ça c'est
le premier point et certes il y a un
ancrage local mais il joue peu on vient
de le dire enfin moins que pour des
municipales on vient de le dire et le
vrai problème c'est que on parlait tout
à l'heure de l'abstention il y aura pas
de triangulaire il y en aura très peu il
y a tout de suite vous imaginez pas une
participation remontée ces mécanique à
cause de l'abstention qui même si elle
n'atteint pas forcément les 51% de la
dernière fois sera de toute façon très
significativement supérieure à ce qu'on
a vu pour la présidentielle quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui où se situe une
partie des circonscriptions sortantes
des on a notamment plein sur le front
nord-est de la France ou Marine Le Pen a
obtenu des scores fleuves à partir du
moment où vous êtes condamnés à être à
finir dans le dans le binôme de tête
dans les deux premiers à l'issue du
premier tour il y a plein d'endroits où
cet ancrage local ne jouera pas parce
qu'ils seront directement effacés il y
aura je pense moi quand même de grosses
pertes au sein des républicains à cause
de ça à cause de cet aspect mécanique
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Joséphine Staron je
rappelle le livre de votre livre Europe
la solidarité contre le naufrage livre
publié aux éditions synopia